[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعدما رفعت محكمه العدل
الدوليه جلستها اترى الاستماع للفريق
القانوني الاسرائيلي في قضيه ارتكاب اباده
جماعيه في قطاع غزه جنوب افريقيا تقول ان
تل ابيب اخفقت في الرد على الادله المقدمه
وانها لم تقدم ما يضح ظ الوقائع التي
اتهمت بها في حين تشهد العديد من المدن
والعواصم العالميه تظاهرات تضامن مع غزه
وللتنديد بالحرب الاسرائيليه على القطاع
تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط
بالتعليق الاول المرشح المؤيد لاستقلال
تايوان لايت شين تي يفوز في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه حسب النتائج الرسميه شبه
النهائيه للاقتراع وكانت الصين قد نددت
مرارا بالمرشح الرئاسي المؤيد لاستقلال
تايوان ووصفته بانه خطر جسيم ووصفت
الانتخابات بانها خيار بين الحرب
والسلامه حكم قضائي على الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب يدفع بموجبه اكثر من
392 الف الولار لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه والى صحفيين فيها كنفقات قضائيه
بعدما رفضت شكوى تقدم بها ضدهم اتهم فيها
الصحفيين باعداد ما وصفها
بمؤامرات ضريبيه
تخصه البنك المركزي الامريكي يسجل في عام
2003 اكبر خساره تشغيليه في تاريخه البالغ
110 سنوات باكثر من 114 مليار دولار دون
ان يتمكن من اعاده اي شيء تقريبا الى
الخزانه ما يفترض ان يفعل عندما يحقق
ارباحا بسبب زياده اسعار الفائده وتراجع
الفوائد التي يحصل عليها من السندات
والاسهم التي يحتفظ بها الى
اللقاء